I hear the voice of my
great-granddaughter seeing a shutdown
Wall Street now here with pulitzer
prize-winning journalist Chris Hedges
Chris thanks so much for taking a moment
to talk to me not all awesome great well
I'd love to talk to you about what's
going on here today what brings you out
well the fact that I think most people
here recognize we've undergone a
corporate coup d'etat and slow-motion
and it's over they've won there is no
way now within this corporate state
which controls the courts controls the
elected officials controls the press
certainly controls all systems of
finance in all forms of government I
mean its corporate lobbyists to write
our legislation it's corporate money
which has replaced the vote which elects
our officials and they do corporate
bidding so for those of us who care
about resting back our democracy as well
as confronting climate change mass acts
of civil disobedience is all we have
left any chance you'll be arrested today
I teach tonight and I teach in a prison
and so I'm that one day a week is kind
of sacred for my students and if it
wasn't tonight I would be I have been
arrested in the past I will certainly be
arrested in the future but on Monday
night I have to be in that prison
there are a number of themes here I mean
climate change is a persistent theme but
there's also a very sort of thick
anti-capitalist sentiment here are the
two things linked in an intrinsic way of
course its corporate capitalism that is
commodified human beings and commodified
the ecosystem that they then exploit
until exhaustion or collapse there are
no internal limits within capitalism you
know as Karl Marx understood and the
fact is if we don't begin to set limits
capitalism has built within it as many
economists have noted a kind of self a
nihilistic force because since it
doesn't have limits it will just push
and push and push until there's nothing
more to exploit well do you see a
difference between cronyism and
capitalism I mean are there any useful
valuable things that capitalism does all
of the great political theorists
starting with Aristotle you know going
up through Max Weber or anywhere else
have understood that the quality is that
going to make someone a good capitalist
do not make them a good student or a
thatíll talked about capitalism
Aristotle talked about an oligarchy and
an oligarchy as being the enemy of
democracy and we certainly live with an
oligarchic system that's so when I think
capitalism I think Adam Smith who called
it the natural system of Liberty this
notion that people own themselves that
they own property that they're able to
exchange it freely with one another for
various things
at its core like that is capitalism this
notion of a free market like how exactly
does that sort of turn everything into a
commodity is it the notion that there's
any ownership at all that's
objectionable because there's no free
market that's a myth you know I mean
let's talk about african-americans in
America
I'm willing to do that okay so let's
talk about the history of
african-americans who built this country
with their hands and their blood their
sweat and what happened what happened
after emancipation white supremacy
stepped in and created a system of
economic control they've refused to give
them any land through sharecropping they
threw them into debt peonage so that the
idea that they're free that that
capitalism is somehow free when you are
not hope brothers don't talk to me a
freedom now most of what you just
described though those are actually
actions of the state this isn't the
market that is turning black people into
subjects that's refusing to allow them
to own property actually the solution
was to empower them and allow them to
own property and to be equal and free
citizens isn't that the solution that is
not what happened after I Manson no I'm
not saying that's what happened but
that's what ought to it isn't the goal
for the white slave owners who's there
the government I'm including you know
once Andrew traction pulled everybody
out for reconstruction then you began
the reign of terror and the rollback the
government just as government works
today on behalf of multinational
semi-finished multinational corporations
right after slavery you saw government
acting on behalf of white southern slave
owners and I'm talking about a northern
government and then and then a
government actually comes in and removes
government's foot from the heat from the
neck of the black person after the civil
rights movement isn't that pretty much
what happened no the problem was that
once Jackson removed the occupation
troops in the south
life became a living hell for black
people and the only force they had that
was kind of any firewall between them
and their former slave holders was the
government right and there's a danger of
sort of meandering down a path about
sort of slavery I wonder though I mean
you're describing you're describing the
state's actions towards blacks it seems
to me that the state's actions and the
actions of the markets sort of the
markets operation free exchange two
totally different things like conflating
the two isn't really useful in
understanding the notion that we have
property rights that we have innovation
that takes place and that people can
exchange goods with one uname innovation
innovation means you throw all of your
manufacturing overseas and you
workers 22 cents an hour to work in
sweatshops in Bangladesh and the America
we had we had I'll do the interview but
you can't interrupt it and and the fact
is what happens to cipro fluish labor in
America they're incarcerated what
happened what happens to superfluous
labor they're incarcerated okay I
understand well there's what I think at
the end of the day though at the end of
the day though when we actually talk
about soy shops we had sweatshops here
people and then we had labor unions
labor unions created the middle class
that's certainly part of that's part of
what happened I mean wage rates wage
rates increase we're actually seeing
wage rates increase in Bangladesh all
over China that is happening at this
stage is it not not by my wage rates but
rage rates are these rates are
increasing these people will have been
brought out of poverty they are leaving
subsistence farms all over China I think
moving to the cities yes moving to the
cities to pursue jobs that's not
happening no it's not you go to so there
is no wealth creation taking place in
China
Florian's aren't being lifted out of
poverty Oh feudal elite just like here
nope so so lots of people haven't been
lifted out of property only a neo feudal
little you can't judge wealth by wages
so when you come and work for a factory
in China and you can't your way just
don't give you enough to eat and when
you don't make your quotas you got to
climb to the top of your dormitory and
jump off and commit suicide which
happens regularly because people are not
paid when you have no protection from
the exploitive class and when the
exploitive class is in bed with the
government then you have to talk about a
form of neo feudalism I think there's
there's a lot of strong language there I
do wonder though is it an appropriate to
take a look at what conditions were like
before like what would leave someone to
leave a subsistence farm and then to go
take a fairly low paying job in a
factory you don't want to be cut off I
grew up in a farm town and you know what
destroyed every small dairy farm were
agribusinesses and I watched these
family farms go down that had been in
the firm and I watched these farmers
kill themselves and and and what
destroyed
subsistence agriculture in India it was
commodity cash crops oh is it the
supermarket a wonderful thing
tree and the apple tree produces so many
apples he don't know what to do so you
go to the supermarket and you give the
supermarket your money and the
supermarket gives you apples in return
and you say I mean the idea that that
that people are actually free and a
system of global capitalism is is it's
just not borne out by economic reality I
won't dominate the rest of your day or
anything I would like to pursue this a
little further if that's ok
the notion commodity cash crops you
scale up at one point in this country
most people were in agriculture at this
stage very few people are actually in
agriculture yet we're able to produce a
tremendous amount of food we do it at a
really really low cost we do it at such
a low cost all over the world that we're
able to feed many more times that then
what other folks might have thought we
actually thought there was a population
crisis at one point in this country we
found a way to feed a global population
crisis in fact we found a way to feed
those people and it's because of these
agro businesses absolutely
some people are harmed when they can no
longer compete with a new method of
doing business but on net it seems to me
that it is better to be able to feed
people in a cheaper and more affordable
way than to hold on to an old an old
model of producing food that is
incredibly labor intensive and really
really expensive it's not cheaper and
more affordable that's cheaper no if you
go into any marginal area including in
parts of this city they are food deserts
because they can't afford to buy
tomatoes that are trucked all the way
across the country from California
I mean globally though globally speaking
and broadly in the United States of
America there is certainly any number of
factors that have to do with the way
that New York City is is operated and
the fact that I can kind of only buy
food at a bodega or a Whole Foods that's
I think is separate and apart from
whether or not people on average have a
higher standard of living than they did
say 40 or 50 years ago the Green
Revolution is something that happened
that improved the quality of people's
lives
I'm willing to accept that there are any
number of shortcomings in the world that
we live in but it seems like we have to
acknowledge the fact that free markets
have been pivotable pivotal in lifting
people out of poverty in providing
innovations and creating a better and
more prosperous world and we can even
afford to live in a cleaner world is
that I mean that seems like a fair State
you think America is a more prosperous
country than we were decades ago
absolutely well I don't know you don't
think you come from another planet then
really I see I see
I see a democratized media that's
incredibly affordable I say half of this
country now lives in either poverty or
near poverty the working class has been
decimated in this country you go into
urban centers like Camden New Jersey and
people are living where I suggest you go
visit you know the idea that you're
talking about free markets went up the
street we have goldman sachs commodity
traders that buy up world futures of
rice wheat corn livestock so that jack
up commodity prices by 200% so people
and I've worked in Africa and seeing I
covered the famine in the Sudan people
literally starve I mean this this this
this vision that you have this economic
vision is not connected to reality and
I'll be finished it's a non reality
based belief system that is peddled by
an oligarchic elite because even this
country I mean you don't have to go far
you can go across the river into parts
of New Jersey go to York I mean you know
walk around the streets of New York
Newark look at the infrastructure look
at how people are struggling don't tell
me we're better off there's just doesn't
make it well there's just no doubt that
there are still poor people there is
still poverty that is not going anyplace
that some you're always going to have
that I think the question becomes
whether or not whether or not you're
actually whether or not you're actually
moving in the direction of a better and
more prosperous society as a consequence
we're not eventually having free
exchange in free trade we're not
we're not we're not moving to better
directions we'll end it there because I
got to do okay I'm not moving to better
direct
you